le contrôle des cours d'eau ça a été un
gros sujet au cours des dernières
semaines surtout en ce qui concerne la
construction de digues pour protéger des
villes de futures inondations comme à
sainte marthe sur le lac
mais ces modifications olonne elles ont
des impacts sur l'environnement dont on
parle de la santé des cours d'eau à la
connexion avec renault bonjour joker il
ya justement une importante étude parue
cette semaine à ce sujet là qui montre
que les cours d'eau sont très très
nombreux sur la planète à avoir des
digues avoir été modifiée oui c'est ça
c'est ce qui ressort de travaux auxquels
ont participé des chercheurs de
l'université mcgill donc leurs études
elle est parue dans la revue nature et
elle montre que le deux tiers des plus
grandes rivières sur terre ont été
transformés par l'humain et elle ne
coule plus librement
donc je cinq rivières les deux tiers des
plus grands rivières c'est énorme c'est
ce qu'en fait c'est ce qu'on voit sur la
carte qu'on voit à l'écran ce moment
donc les cours d'eau en rouge sondés et
rivières qui ont été transformés ou qui
ne colle plus librement qui ont été
modifiées par l'humain ce qui est en
bleu c'est ce qui est encore libre
donc on voit qu'il est juste des régions
dans le bassin de l'amazone dans le
bassin du congo en afrique est un peu
autour du cirque l'arctique mais pour le
reste c'est tout des régions où on ne
bloque par exemple va être retenu par
des barrages ou de l'eau qui va
détourner par des canaux donc ça
implique aussi des plaines inondables
qui sont bloqués par des digues ou au
contraire qu'ils sont totalement
totalement submergé par des canaux et
par des réservoirs et ses modifications
l'os c'est sûr qu'elles sont importantes
pour les communautés qui vont vivre
autour ça va empêcher les inondations ça
va produire de l'élite de l'île de
l'électricité ou de l'eau potable
mais quand on les prend à l'échelle du
globe ça ces changements le prennent des
proportions immenses et les chercheurs
comme sur la carte qu'on a vu il ya
quelques instants
ils ont cartographie 12 millions de
kilomètres de rivières pendant plus
d'une décennie donc soit 5 lui et 246
cordeau de 1000 kilomètres et plus au
total c'est environ 41 % du volume des
rivières de la terre cette masse d'eau
là un rôle extrêmement important pour
les écosystèmes et si les deux tiers
d'entre elles ne remplissent plus leur
rôle mais sans avoir des conséquences
importantes sur la biodiversité mais
aussi sur les communautés qui vivent
autour paris c'est clair et quand on
parle du rôle d'une rivière qu'est-ce
que ça inclut au juste
mais donc l'eau d'une rivière faut dire
que ça circule pas si c'est pas un
simple circulaire
si on en suivant le courant d'amont en
aval lowepro ci se déplacer latéralement
donc en débordant des rivières en allant
dans les plaines inondables et peut
aussi aller ça peut aussi se déplacer
sous terre à peu à lire dans l'aquifère
ou dans les réservoirs souterrains 80
tous ses déplacements les rivières vont
transporter des sédiments qui jouent des
éléments organiques qui vont lui
permettre de remplir des rôles comme la
production d'eau potable de façon
naturelle apporter des sédiments qui
vont protéger les berges de l'érosion ou
même enrichir les territoires agricoles
ça peut aussi être important pour les
populations animales des zones humides
les poissons d'eau douce et tout ça et
tous ces rôles sont compromis quand on
bloque les échanges le long des cours
d'eau avec des digues ou des barrages
c'est sûr qu'à l'échelle locale ça peut
avoir l'air peu importants mais à grande
échelle les répercussions sont
importantes et les chercheurs ont montré
comme on le dit qu'à l'exception de ces
trois grandes régions mais la plupart
des rivières du monde remplissent plus
leur rôle comme elle le devrait il a on
parle de quel genre de conséquences à ce
moment là bon si on pense si on ramène
sont par exemple au canada la
segmentation des cours d'eau ça peut
diminuer la capacité de leurs capacités
des limites d'éliminer des polluants qui
viennent de ville ou de régions
agricoles que ça ça peut empirer des
épisodes par exemple où il ya des
proliférations d'algues microscopiques
qui peuvent tuer des poissons et
polluent encore plus les cours d'eau
pour un fleuve comme le saint-laurent ça
peut vouloir dire aussi moins de
sédiments qui vont se rendre jusque dans
l'estuaire est sûre ça peut menacer
plusieurs formes de vie qui s'y trouvent
et hans à l'étude des chercheurs de
mcgill rejoint un peu le rapport de
l'onu qui est parue lundi dernier en ce
qui concerne la diminution de toute la
biodiversité sur terre parce qu'on sait
que des espèces qui utilisent les
rivières pour migrer elles sont
particulièrement vulnérables quand leurs
trajectoires leur trajet est coupée ou
quand la composition de l'eau change
brutalement au chemin qu'on peut voir
quand il ya des égos des barrages et
faut rappeler qu'à l'échelle du monde il
ya deux milliards de personnes qui
puisent leur eau potable directement
dans les rivières et on extrait thierry
viala 12 millions de tonnes de poissons
qui servent à l'alimentation mondiale
donc tout ça va être menacée si on
modifie trop nos cours d'eau sa frappe à
nouveau ses chefs là comme à grande
échelle qu'on voit l'ensemble des
chiffres c'est sûr que ça c'est
impressionnant dit quand on est un petit
échelon on se dit que ça n'a pas
d'importance mais quand on voit tout le
monde fait pareil
le ca des conséquences importantes ce
qui peut être fait
pour contrer ça trop tard non mais c'est
sûr que c'est difficile d'imaginer une
solution concrète un problème aussi
vaste aux etats-unis par exemple on a vu
par exemple dans certains cas des
barrages ont été démantelés pour sauver
et pour protéger la biodiversité ou
l'environnement d'une rivière ça a
fonctionné dans certains comme est pas
une solution qu'on peut appliquer
partout donc l'étude des chercheurs de
mcgill
elle au moins le souligne le problème à
l'échelle du globe c'est un premier
recensement qui pourrait permettre aux
décideurs de différents partis
gouvernementaux de prendre des décisions
pour mieux protéger nos rivières et
qu'on comprend justement plus la valeur
environnementale mais aussi sociales et
économiques des rivières mais c'est là
qu'on peut être en mesure de les gérer
plus adéquat plaisir si bien